another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do  no bets concerning xk class end of the  world scenarios it's the one thing we  hope to avoid an xk-class scenario an  event that results in the complete and  utter destruction of the world most of  us prefer not to think about it at all  unless we're actively trying to prevent  it not dr bright though he sees the  apocalypse as a chance to make a quick  buck dr bright is officially prohibited  from making accepting or taking any rake  off bets related to xk class scenarios  these include but are not limited to  i'll bet you a thousand bucks the robots  get us first it'll all start with ducks  and not with a bang but with a whimper